the skies over Bristol are filled with
hot air balloons for one long weekend
founded 35 years ago it has become the
biggest event of its kind in europe this
use Fiesta seized over 120 belounis from
across the world this time around
however there's to be no mass launch on
the first morning maybe a few people fly
but I don't think many will fly free
this morning if you look at the clothes
you can see they're going along quite
quickly so this means that there's a
high wind a little bit above the ground
and as the air mixes during the day that
will be a high wind at the surface makes
landing a little bit difficult Don
Camryn is the festival's founder now 74
The Scotsman was the first man to cross
the Sahara and the alps by balloon and
the second to make it across the
Atlantic the organizers have said this
morning that only pilots with more than
250 hours may fly because conditions
will be a little bit difficult the joint
start involves only a handful of
balloons instead of 120 but there's no
shortage of spectators with some having
arrived as early as the pilots at 5am
over the four days the organizers are as
usual expecting half a million visitors
our first time to have a little
basketball and
it's really great
I'm disappointed they can't all go up
together but I think it's because of the
weather Simon Watley is an amateur
balloonist from Bristol Jenny McLaughlin
and andy bennett are locals they won
this high-altitude trip in a radio
competition
bit nervous but excited up up and away
let's go with the wind so in Bristol if
you can get any direction this is quite
common because you have the the Bristol
Channel Tunnel sea air Bristol is also
home to Cameron balloons the world's
largest manufacturer of hot air balloons
the firm was founded by John Cameron in
1971 the boss is currently at the Fiesta
grants for production continues unabated
the firm has customers around the globe
Nick Purvis has worked here for 32 years
there's a sporting market which you
would find very typically in Europe
there is the Safari and tourist market
which you would find in places like
Kenya in the turkey in Egypt where
people go for a balloon safari rides and
then there's a competition market where
people are using balloons for racing or
four expeditions traveling across
continents and oceans and that's a very
specialist part of our market each
balloons fabric known as an envelope is
made using all sewing machines there's a
good reason for that our balloons go all
over the world and one of the things
that we've got to remember is that
windsor safari balloons as we have here
on my left are out in the bush if they
get damaged they need to be repaired on
a simple machine with very
unsophisticated techniques we have to
produce a balloon that's
full of being serviced by such simple
means and hence we don't use specialist
machines for much of our work
the ride in Simon wat Lee's gondola and
some two hours later around 30
kilometers from the balloon fiesta
groans the pilots are picked up by their
teams once they've located them another
festival highlights are the night
clothes here balloons light up the night
sky accompanied by musical rhythms